[Music]
videogames are risky endeavors they cost
excessive time money and brainpower to
make even with major publishers funding
the process there is no guarantee there
will be a solid financial payoff in the
end one result of this is the ubiquitous
franchise building we've seen throughout
the mediums history rather than bet on a
creative new IP the vast majority of
video games are sequels relying on brand
awareness and name recognition to drive
consumer interest this isn't just
consigned to games many films do this
focusing less on individual stories than
how each new movie will fit into the
Marvel Cinematic Universe or build
toward the Justice League release
television does this with spin-offs
pushing supporting characters into
starring roles and building off the
success of established series so in this
world of franchise ubiquity it's all the
more refreshing when a spin-off series
is good it's exciting when a DC film
stands on its own it's thrilling when a
videogame sequel can carve its own path
dive deeper into the ideas of its
predecessor and emerge as a special
experience in itself
Wolfenstein 2 the new Colossus is one
such game and future sequels should take
note and the greedy money men of Wall
Street it was gonna send the children of
the proletariat off to dive foreign
lands so that they could be filling
their coffers it worked their sons
blatant on the beaches
I got kids on the way and I'll be damned
if I'm gonna raise them in the world rum
potty not yet throughout the last year
I've been lucky enough to visit numerous
development studios interviewing the
creators of games such as mafia 3 Middle
Earth shadow of war Resident Evil 7
civilization 6 and Tacoma to name a few
I also got the chance to hang out with
Harvey Smith as the creative director at
Arcana of the dishonored series he's no
stranger to the unique challenges that
sequel creation entails with this
honored one you're trying to convey to
everyone what is this thing you know
what's different about it what is it
with the Sun or two you don't have that
challenge of getting it because a lot of
people are already excited about it you
have other challenges how much do you
reinvent it because if it's too familiar
people are like ah feels like a 1.5 if
it's too different they're like wow you
deviated from the pattern that I love
and I can tell you from experience
that's a really tricky balance I happen
to think dishonor to was a fantastic
sequel it did a great job of as Smith
said being different
without being too different it took the
ideas set forth by its predecessor
introduced new mechanics into the fold
and just went deeper with the series
gameplay tenants but other sequels
haven't fared as well take the recent
Middle Earth shadow of war for instance
it's an extremely fun Lord of the Rings
game at its best it uses its clever
Nemesis system to let you find your own
story among the politics of more doors
orc armies but the rest of the time I
actually think shadow of war tried to do
too much it bogs it's more brilliant
moments down with baggage there are
weapons - fine armor together
collectables to hoard and a marketplace
plagued with microtransactions it didn't
completely forget what made the original
great to begin with but it didn't
exactly complement it either on the
other end of the spectrum we have the
recent Assassin's Creed origins as with
shadow of war origins is a good game in
its own right however I think Ubisoft's
newest entry in the long-running
franchise should have done more than it
does it reworks the combat mechanics a
little and attempts to open its world up
to
or exploration than its predecessors but
the resulting experience still feels a
bit stale as was the case with
Assassin's Creed syndicate and unity
before it origins often tasks you with
side quests that don't add to the game
they're just sort of they're these shaky
steps make it all the more apparent how
much of a masterclass Wolfenstein 2 is
in sequel creation it amplifies the
qualities of the first game and polishes
most of its flaws it also adds its own
systems that make it a stellar journey
on its own without sacrificing that
Wolfenstein feel many people are
expecting I'll trust you blaskowitz
there's nothing saying you couldn't be
wearing a mask made it look like William
J blessed wish to hide your alien space
lizard facial traits so I mean the past
week grace gave you she didn't give me
one right off with a mask
show me your lizard face [ __ ]
super special lower your weapon front
break your armor but you're like the new
Colossus begins almost immediately after
the new orders ending our hero BJ
blaskowitz is clinging to life after his
battle with general death said he slowly
recovers and once again he's called upon
to kill some Nazis I won't go too much
into spoiler territory from this point
forward but if you want to play the new
Colossus from a completely fresh
perspective pause the video go play it
and come back in a couple days I promise
it's well worth your time
[Music]
anyway
[Music]
wolfenstein to story is fantastic not
just because of its own momentum but how
it develops already established
characters and plot points in a
meaningful way it goes back in time to
show us BJ's childhood it explores how
his Jewish mother and abusive father
clashed it shows us how BJ got to this
point and suggests how he might move
forward it develops existing
relationships it creates new ones and it
destroys others and despite Wolfenstein
z-- focus on shooting and stabbing this
entry isn't afraid to explore the
aftermath of those things the trauma and
exhaustion that come with constant
fighting and violence at one point in
the new Colossus BJ breaks down and
literally can't do it anymore this
patriotic macho man admits that he
cannot go on how he manages to do so is
another story entirely and it
encapsulates just how batshit crazy the
new Colossus is willing to become
speaking of this super also marks a
tonal shift as well although I love the
new order it's somber tone often felt
heavily at odds with its murdering Nazis
gameplay this time around however
developer machinegames has embraced the
bombast of its narrative don't get me
wrong there are plenty of dark moments
throughout the sequel but the new
Colossus finds a better balance between
swagger and desperation it's characters
are at once touching and hilarious the
new Colossus is an uprising fuelled by
tender moments and machine-gun riffs
alike and here it's all of a piece this
is a video game however and a good story
isn't always enough on its own for the
sequel machine games needed to iterate
on gameplay mechanics pacing and design
as well and here too the team succeeded
[Music]
the new order had a variety of pacing
problems too often relying on sandbox
environments to let you choose between
stealth or a louder approach the new
Colossus however hurls a plethora of
scenarios at you over the course of its
campaign it still does a great job of
allowing for different plans of attack
but it does so in more creative ways you
have access to three contraptions or
these mechanical superpowers that let
you navigate levels through brute force
sneak attacks or higher vantage points
the combat is about more than shooting
and cover it's also about using the
environment to your advantage it's about
asking yourself questions and answering
them quickly is this Factory better
suited for a close-quarters combat do I
have enough ammo to take down that
panzer hood can I cross this gap with my
current health or should I stock up
before making my run the new Colossus
also offers a handful of optional side
missions at your HQ and in the field
they lead to additional upgrades for BJ
but they also help the pacing they're
great bookends to the spectacle of each
main mission they're excuses to return
to areas you've already visited with new
objectives and aesthetics in mind you
can find new routes through the
battlefield
you can keep your enemies at a distance
this time around or you can avoid them
completely opting we'll need to kill
when you absolutely need to although the
new order tried to let you play at your
own pace the new Colossus has actually
refined that tactic and it's a better
overall experience because of it I don't
envy developers having to rely on
sequels as Smith said in regards to
Dishonored creating a new IP is its own
challenge but expanding upon it while
also retaining existing fans is another
problem entirely Studios run the risk of
doing too much they run the risk of not
doing enough the best sequels however
find ways to strike that balance the new
Colossus is a shining example it
developed its characters while also
asking us to reconsider them it
maintains the gritty feel of the new
order while also amplifying it this time
around it hones its pacing structure and
mechanics creating a superb experience
in the long run it's an instant classic
and any sequel moving forward should
take no
[Music]
you